[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es einen apfel spekulatius
kuchen mit einer karamellsoße und der
kuchen und die karamellsoße sind beide
vegan
heute lasse ich den morath probieren und
später noch einen freund von uns der
kuchen besteht aus einem rührteig den
habe ich unten in der mitte ist dann die
apfel schichtung obendrüber noch ne
krümmel also eine streusel schicht
richtig lecker und vor allem könnte den
kuchen einmal packen und wirklich ein
paar tage davon essen da ist wirklich
super lecker und sehr saftig los geht's
zuerst einmal mit der abfüllung dass
spekulatius gewürze verwende ich drei
teelöffel zimt einen halben teelöffel
pfeffer einen halben teelöffel kalium
und einen teelöffel immer einen
teelöffel welche und einen teelöffel
muskat blüte und für die abfüllung
verwende ich 800 gramm äpfel mit schale
den abrieb und saft von 1 zitrone etwas
wein extrakt zucker eine prise salz und
stärke jetzt verriet jetzt auch
spekulativ gewürzt und da habe ich jetzt
mehr größere menge und kann die dann
einfach aufbewahren und auch was anderes
damit partner und dafür wird hier
einfach alle gewürze zum beispiel direkt
in einem schraubglas könnens aufbewahren
und auch darin direkt drittel
[Musik]
das gewürz stelle ich jetzt kurz zur
seite und kann jetzt schon mal die äpfel
nehmen entkernen und dann fein würfeln
da war sie jetzt einfach die schale dran
der klassiker
[Musik]
und die äpfel gebe ich dann direkt in
eine große schüssel da reibe ich auch
jetzt erstmal noch die zitrone dazu den
abtrieb und dafür nehme ich natürlich
eine unbehandelte zitrone
da kann ich nämlich direkt auch die
zitrone so ein bisschen kneten da kommt
der saft besser raus halbieren und den
saft auspressen damit die äpfel einfach
nicht brauchen werden und dann gebe ich
da jetzt gleich alle apfel würfel mit
dazu
[Musik]
das habe ich die äpfel mit dem
zitronensaft in der zitronenschale
verrührt jetzt kommt hier ein bisschen
mannil xtrac dazu was war für dich nicht
wäre dann etwas salz und zucker zucker
könnt ihr natürlich nach geschmack dazu
geben die stärke und natürlich das
spekulations gesetzt es gibt jetzt etwa
einem teelöffel dazu aber das macht ihr
dann einfach nach geschmack kann ich die
abfüllung gut verrühren und dann kurz
beiseite stellen und schon mal die
streusel zu bereiten
[Musik]
für die streusel verwende ich 50 gramm
kokosöl 50 gramm koks blüten zucker eine
prise salz 50 gramm mehl 50 gramm
kernigen haferflocken 30 g gehackte
mandeln und einem teelöffel spekulatius
gewürze ich hab jetzt hier das kokosöl
das gebe ich jetzt hier eben der
rührschüssel da kam das salz dazu der
cocos blüten zucker und das mehl
ihr könnt natürlich auch ganz normalen
zucker verwenden und ich habe jetzt hier
einfach als mutterersatz kokosöl
genommen das ergebnis der gast kommt man
schon was durch wandel jetzt kurz alles
verbinden
hinter am besten man auch einfach direkt
die hand für sträuße braucht man echt
keine küchenmaschine
es gebe ich dann noch durch spekulatives
gesetz dazu sie ist auch schon raus hat
bröselte spekulatius kekse und richtet
auch so und jetzt gebe ich hier noch die
haferflocken mit dazu die könnt ihr dazu
geben müsst aber nicht und die mandeln
dann einfach alles tritt fassen
wenn ihr es eher kerniger mögt dann eben
auch so wie ich kenne gehabt wochen
ansonsten positiven nehmen wir für die
streusel auch bereit und was wird mit
den rührteig verwende ich 200 gramm je
200 gramm zucker eine prise salz jeweils
einen halben teelöffel natron und
backpulver etwas will extrakt 150
milliliter mineralwasser 50 gramm
apfelmus 50 milliliter sonnenblumenöl
und einen esslöffel essig die streusel
habe ich jetzt umgefüllt und kann es
einfach die gleiche schüssel benutzen
also die musste auch nicht auswaschen
jetzt kommen hier die trockenen zutaten
rein backpulver natron salz und zucker
wie kann ich jetzt kurz verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich hier noch die übrigen
zutaten mit rein also etwas von extrakt
[Musik]
dann apfelmus und apfelmus dient hier
immer so ein bisschen als ersatz muss ja
irgendwie auch die zutaten ersetzen oder
teig sonja auch trotzdem luftig werden
und schön zusammen bleiben
ich habe einmal vergessen bei brauchen
eier zuzufügen und der teig wurde
einfach nie fest weil einfach was
gefehlt hat
ein bisschen wasser wird er locker
lässig und den essig nehme ich jetzt mit
dazu einfach eben auch wegen dem natron
auch ein bisschen säure brauch zum
aufgeben und jetzt die zutaten kurz
verwirren
jetzt nehme ich meine bakri dann habe
ich bereits auf 25 cm eingestellt und
schlag den mit backpapier ein weil ich
aber in den selbigen tag haben
[Musik]
da kann ich jetzt den teig einfüllen
wer es noch richtig winterlich
weihnachtliche machen möchte kann hier
auf matt haben zufügen marzipanrohmasse
dies nämlich auch vegan
[Musik]
ich weiß ganz ist der vulkan und
marzipan markt wegen lass ich lieber mal
weg aber wie gesagt hier können dass auf
jeden fall zu fügen
ich für mich wird auf jeden fall machen
kommen hier die äpfel drauf hier könnt
ihr natürlich auch birnen und kirschen
marinen alles was ihr wollt
[Musik]
jetzt kommen hier noch die streusel
drauf
[Musik]
ab in den augen
den apfelkuchen habe ich nach dem backen
einfach abkühlen lassen und dann noch
mal in den kühlschrank gestellt und
jetzt werde ich noch eine vegane
karamellsoße machen für die vegane
karamellsoße verwende ich 200 gramm
braunem zucker eine prise salz 50
milliliter wasser 150 milliliter
kokosmilch und etwas manila extrakt den
kuchen habe ich jetzt übrigens auch
schon glitzer schnee bestreut gleicht
der afrika und dadurch wird der kuchen
natürlich noch mal ein bisschen schöner
ich nehme jetzt hier einen topf und gibt
den braunen zucker hinein
ihr könnt dann natürlich auch weißen
zucker nehmen aber der braune zucker der
hat schon so ein cara mehligen geschmack
und sehen das jetzt hier erstmal ein
bisschen karamellisieren und in einem
zweiten topf werde ich schon mal die
kokosmilch erhitzen damit sie später
einfach nicht so kalt ist
[Applaus]
und damit der zucker nicht anbrennt
nehme ich hier noch das wasser gibt es
dazu
[Applaus]
so kann nämlich der zucker ganz
gleichmäßig schmelzen und anschließend
karamellisieren
[Musik]
beim braunen zucker hat man natürlich
den nachteil dass man nicht sieht weil
karamellisiert aber ihr könnt da auf die
bläschen achten
die werden nämlich immer kleiner und
feiner da muss man jetzt ein bisschen
nach gefühl gehen die kokosmilch ist
jetzt auch schon warm die gebe ich jetzt
hier langsam und vorsichtig dazu
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich die kokosmilch gemeinsam
mit dem zucker noch ein bisschen
einkochen gebe jetzt hier für den
geschmack noch vanille extrakt dazu und
zum abrunden des geschmacks noch etwas
zeit
nicht einfach so zwei bis drei minuten
nochmal köcheln lassen
[Musik]
nein
zum glück habe ich einen induktionsherd
jetzt brenne nämlich nicht sagen als
zwei bis drei minuten bei geringer hitze
köcheln lassen versorgung hat
wenn er ohne thermometer arbeitet dann
könnt ihr trotzdem testen ob die
karamellsoße gut ist und zwar gibt die
einfach ein bisschen was auf einen
teller und jetzt sieht man hier auch
schon dass die hier so langsam abkühlt
und dickflüssiger wird jetzt im
flüssigen zustand ist natürlich noch
sehr flüssig aber es ist ja auch sehr
heiß
und hier sehe ich jetzt schon dass sie
schon richtig dick vom löffel läuft
deswegen nehme ich die jetzt vom herd
herunter fühlen sie entlastet abkühlen
im ist halt im prinzip entscheiden
wollte eine warme karamell server oder
eine ganz kalte und ich lasse jetzt kalt
abkühlen weil ich sie so denn eben auch
optimal lagern kann
[Musik]
jetzt ist die karamellsoße lauwarm
abgekühlt und ich habe sich angefühlt
und murat und sonntag stehen in den
startlöchern und dürfen probieren kommt
rein jörg schneider ich den kuchen an
ja man muss auch sagen sowohl kann ist
veganer der schon seit zwei monaten bei
uns und wie soll ich sagen also dann
versucht uns immer zu legalisieren also
nicht machen sondern einen nicht
militant meine ich jetzt der versucht
mit sieben sachen zu zeigen wie müssen
sich vegan machen und kochen halb daheim
zusammen und backpapier macht und
deswegen kennt es nicht das hier ist
nicht auch wieder ganz klar und
angespannten wohnungsmarkt oder ob ich
es mag ja eigentlich aufs morath mag ich
glaube der ball kam mag sondern ist noch
nicht mal war das wagen das aber
probiert aber er riecht schon genau
darüber gespannt ob es mehr als eine
alternativ ist und dass spekulatius
gewirkt habe ich selber gemacht so kommt
ihr die karamellsoße drüber
ich meine mit glitzer genieren
karamellsoße und ich viel falsch machen
[Musik]
jungs probiert mal und beim vegan
bekenntnis sagen es gibt ganz ganz coole
dinge diesen welchen mehr als ein
einzelner team und er war kann ich es
kein militanter mai kabine
es gibt ja wirklich vegan timo hawaiis
zu
woher weißt du das ist auf jeden fall
jetzt wo ich mal butter der murat macht
ja immer so ein großes thema traurig der
vulkan gar nicht erst wollte immer der
moral und schmeckten hafen und
spekulatius
ich find's super ich will es jetzt ein
bisschen zu süß karamellsoße das hat der
kamenzer ja was ich als bisher
haben hier ich will aber ein bisschen
mehr karamellsoße für alle veganer nicht
veganer und schöner weihnachtlicher
kuchen ja jetzt definitiv weil das nicht
willst du denn auch nach machen also
falls ihr den kuchen auch nach machen
wollt dann schaut auf meinem blog vorbei
ließ - blog.de da steht das rezept noch
mal ganz genau
die karamellsoße könnt ihr übrigens auch
super aufbewahren einfach in ein
schraubglas und dann in den kühlschrank
oder sogar bei raumtemperatur das klappt
auch und wünsche euch viel spaß und nach
backen und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
hohoho
einfach sich buck heute weihnachtsbasar
die normalerweise jeder kauft
christstollen dominosteine und lebkuchen
selberbacken lohnt sich auf jeden fall
weist zum einen besten schmeckt und ist
ganz so aufwendig ist wie viele denken
und sonnigsten ist gebacken und mit
liebe gemacht und handgemacht und dann
ist weihnachten finde ich doch so schön
einfach sally sonntag 15 55